Welcome back to State of the Union
I'm Caitlin Collins.
A preview of a potential 2024
showdown between the former president
and the former vice president as
Mike Pence unveiled
a new attack on his former boss
behind closed doors in Washington
last night.
What is the emerging power
struggle, though,
mean for the future of the direc
of the Republican Party?
Joining me now
to discuss is Republican
Congresswoman of South Carolina,
Nancy Mace.
Congressman,
thank you so much for being here
this morning.
I want to start
with the scathing comments
we heard from former Vice
President Pence last night.
He said,
I know that history will hold
Donald Trump accountable for Jan
Do you think he's right?
And good morning, Caitlin.
Thank you for having me on this
I see this in two parts.
I think both sides are really st
looking at the nomination proces
You've got
some on the left
that don't want Biden to run.
You've got those on the right
that don't want the former presi
to run.
You know,
a lot of folks on both sides
keep bringing up January six and
it's keeping us from
moving our country forward.
I was very vocal
about January six myself.
I'm one of the only Republicans
in the House
who defeated the former presiden
in a primary last year, went on
my general election
in a purple district resoundingl
We've got to unite behind
a candidate in 24
who can win the White House
if we're serious about it.
There's a lot at stake right now
Well,
given that
Trump is the frontrunner
of the Republican field right no
so do you think he has been held
accountable for January six?
Well,
he's one of the
only candidates in right now.
And I imagine by June and July
this summer,
you'll see more than two
or three candidates in that race
The Iowa caucuses
aren't for another 330 days,
and that's the start of it.
I'm proud of my home
state of South Carolina.
We will be the first in the Sout
presidential primary next year.
We have a long way to go
for additional candidates
to jump in
and see how the field lays out.
On January six, Marjorie Taylor
and Congressman James Comer,
who's the chair
of the Oversight Committee
that you serve on,
have been planning a trip
to visit
January six defendants who are i
What do you make of that?
Would you join them on a trip li
I'm not joining in
them, but I'll say this.
I've done
a lot of civil rights work
over the years as a state lawmak
and as a member of Congress.
In fact,
the very first bill ever filed o
work on in
my freshman year
was that they came
Jeffries on a civil rights
piece of legislation.
I would tell you, anyone
who is sitting in solitary confi
or sitting in jail,
regardless of
of their political affiliation,
if they feel like their civil
rights have been violated,
then we as members of Congress
should help them
And this is something
that I've worked on a lot over t
and something that I respect.
I was the ranking member
on the Civil
Rights
Committee on Oversight with Jami
last year
That's something
that we should all care about,
the constitutional rights of cit
of this country.
But given that the other thing
that Pence said last night was
he said it mocks decency to port
what happened on January six as
as sightseers.
Obviously, we saw that happen on
this week after House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
gave them 40000 hours of footage
You have said you want other peo
to get that footage.
Was it a mistake, though, for hi
to only give it to to one outlet
to portray it as they did
I said
early on last month
that the release of the footage
was important,
that it should be released
to every outlet, including CNN,
every media outlet,
every defense attorney,
so that the public can see for i
And there there was violence on
You cannot deny that.
And, you know,
it was a dark day in our history
but so, too, were
was the summer of 20, 20.
We saw very few arrests
when there are attacks
by an organization, members of A
and Black Lives Matter.
I had my house spray
painted two summers ago
and no one's
been held to account for that.
And so we've got to make sure
if there's going to be
political violence in this count
no matter your political affilia
everybody is treated
and should be treated the same w
And we agree
that CNN should also get access
to that footage.
Many media outlets would.
I want to talk to you about the
because you just heard
from the White House
budget director
about President Biden's proposal
When are Republicans going to re
their proposal?
I would like to know that as wel
There's been a lot of discussion
internally about what
that might look like.
The Freedom Caucus has put there
We're still having that discussi
I will tell you in the comments
by the director of OMB on this p
a few minutes ago
were disturbing to me,
just not even as a member of Con
But as an American,
that this is non-negotiable.
The administration is talking
about a $5 trillion tax hike.
That is not tenable
for individuals and businesses,
given the inflation
that we're facing right
now, given the
possible recession
that we're heading into.
We should be negotiating on this
This shouldn't be one sided
because both sides,
Republicans and Democrats alike,
have caused the inflation
that we're in today.
They've caused the $31 trillion
that we're facing right now.
Both sides
should be sitting at the table
and coming up with a reasonable
Let's just say
over ten years to tackle
spending, to tackle taxes,
to tackle inflation
so that we can get on with this
and grow the economy in a way
that can tackle the $31 trillion
deficit that we have.
Let's just say over ten years.
I don't think that's a lot to as
I should note the White House's
they say, would
it would reduce the deficit
by about 3 trillion over ten yea
But you just mentioned that prop
from the House Freedom Caucus.
Do you agree with that proposal?
I haven't read it
in detail,
so I don't want to make a commen
If I don't know
the specifics of the plan.
The president's plan just came o
I did read some media reports
that said
it would not reduce the deficit.
And so I want to look at it
with an open mind and look at it
from the economists
from both sides of the aisle
to figure out what it is.
But what I did
read was a $5 trillion tax
hike on individuals and business
And if you're going to be seriou
about inflation, for example,
there are a number of things
that we have to do.
You have to tackle spending.
You've got to look at how we're
taxpayer dollars.
You have to look at lowering tax
You have to also grow the econom
exponentially in a way so that i
you can take over the inflation
and the deficit issues
that we have right now.
That's what you got to do. Yeah.
And we should know
you can't do it by raising taxes
The White House's plan
is basically dead on arrival,
giving Republicans
control the majority in the Hous
We'll wait to see when Republica
do release their plan.
I want to ask you
about the collapse of SBB.
That is something that everyone
waiting to see.
What happens when markets open
tomorrow morning as a member of
Do you think that they should
get bailed out by the federal go
It's still
it's still very
early to see or say
what the ramifications are going
That was a unique bank
that mostly serves
startups in Silicon Valley.
And those customers
have been hit by inflation.
They've been hit by interest rat
They're low on cash.
There is also
it sounds like a panic run
by some of their larger companie
Last week,
the CEO sold himself
millions of dollars of stock
and gave his employees,
I read this morning
bonuses
right before the government took
the bank.
You know,
we cannot
keep bailing out private compani
because there's no consequences
to their actions.
People
when they make mistakes or break
the law, have to be held account
in this country.
Okay, so just to confirm,
you don't support a bailout, rig
Is that what you're saying?
Not at this time.
I would.
It's still very early.
Again, it's
I don't even think
been 48 hours,
but at this time
I would not support a bailout.
I want to ask you about somethin
your fellow South Carolinian
Nikki Haley, said.
Obviously,
she is running for president in
She said this week that she supp
the raising
the retirement age for four peop
who are in their twenties
when it comes to receiving
Social Security benefits.
Do you agree with her on that?
I think that's something
that has to be on the table.
We have to look at.
I'm 45 years old.
I'm assuming that
that Social Security
will be insolvent,
that I won't have retirement fun
from what I put into
in my adult life, my working lif
We do have to look at Social Sec
We've got to look at our spendin
in this country.
Mandatory and discretionary.
If we're going to take on fixing
the Medicare, Medicaid, Social S
you name it,
we've got to get serious about i
Okay.
So you do you do support potenti
raising the age to maybe extend
as long
as long as it's not anybody
that's heading into retirement r
We do not want to take away
those that are in retirement.
Or those
that are heading into retirement
But we're talking
about younger generations.
My kids, for example,
if they know what the
what the retirement
will look like 40 years
from now, 50 years from now,
then that should be on the table
and can be.
We have to both Republicans and
have screwed this thing up and
they've got to fix it.